ليس مستغربا هنا في بريطانيا ان تطول مده
الانتظار في قسم الطوارئ لاربع او خمس
ساعات وليس خارجا عن المالوف ان ينتظر
المرضى شهورا لرؤيه الطبيب فهناك حوالي
سبعه ملايين ومئه الف شخص في بريطانيا على
لائحه الانتظار وذلك في اعلى حصيله تسجلها
بريطانيا في تاريخ قطاعها الصحي ويبدو ان
هذا القطاع يتجه نحو الاسوء مع اعلاني
اكمل نقابه للممرضين المضيق دوما في
اضرابا قد يشمل مليون موظف في مختلف اقسام
قطاع التمريض
رساله للجميع عاليه وواضحه مئه الاف
الممرضين والممرضات والتحدث اليوم وقالوا
كفاه هذا يكفي لقد حوله غضبهم الى فعل على
امتداد المملكه المتحده وفي كل اقسام خدمه
الصحه الوطنيه
واثار القرار تخوفا بين المرضى خاصه
المرضى الامراض المستعصيه مثل السرطان
الذين وصلت مده انتظارهم للعلاج اكثر من
60 يوما
ولكن هناك مطالب برفع الاجور سيعاني
العديد واذا فقد احدهم حياته بسبب الاضراب
فان الامر عائد لضميرهم لقد انتظرته لمده
11 شهرا لموعد اليوم اشعر بالاسف انهم
يريدون الاضراب من الغريب ان العاملين في
خدمه الصحه الوطنيه
في البلاد الذي باتى غير قادر على استيعاب
كافه المرضى وسط نيه الحكومه للمزيد من
التقشف وهو ما قد يخاطر بتراجع اداء
المستشفيات على حساب بصحه البريطانيين
والمقيمين هنا
مين لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه